I'm sorry I'm not there at the moment
I'm very busy however many happy returns
I'm gonna be with you again very soon
hey youtubers happy who like week so
this is my review of the Sherlock mini
episode many happy returns the BBC has
also been releasing some extra content
as part of that as well just a heads up
I was originally going to be posting a
breakdown of how I think Sherlock
survived the fall but I'm just gonna be
posting that tomorrow instead also be
posting my review the Doctor Who
Christmas special tomorrow - I'll be
giving away a lot of fun stuff so be
sure and subscribe to get those videos
so here are 10 big takeaways from the
mini episode number one it's a prequel
it's very tongue-in-cheek and it's meant
to just set up some of the more dramatic
moments that will happen during the
first episode empty hearse
number two the BBC added a new post to
Watson's blog wherein he tells everyone
he's giving up crime solving and moving
on after Sherlock's death it's been
about two years number three the
timeline episode one takes place two
years after the events of Reichenbach
Fall
this mini episode takes place months
before that episode so we can assume
that it's at least a year and a half
after series two number four the
moustache notice that Watson does not
have a moustache in this video in the
first episode empty hearse he has a
lumberjack quality moustache confirming
the timeline of where the mini episode
sits in relation to series 2 in series 3
number 5 Anderson's noble quest the last
time we saw Anderson he wasn't much of a
friend to Sherlock but now he's gone
completely nuts trying to prove that
Sherlock is solving crimes all over the
world
he's so consumed he's lost his job
they're essentially setting him up to be
a new Molly type figure helping Team
Sherlock from inside the police part of
me is worried that he'll become
sympathetic we'll grow to love him and
then Steven Moffat will kill him classic
trick you start loving a secondary
character then BAM they die number 6 the
pattern on the map Sherlock doesn't play
games like Moriarty did but he does like
riddles the trail that his crime solving
is leaving on the map that Andersen has
been reading is a cipher telling Watson
and anyone else clever enough to read it
that he's coming back Watson and
Lestrade have obviously moved on or
don't care so that's why Anderson is the
only one trying to solve the riddle of
Sherlock's return number 7 the DVD
it was great fanservice and Sherlock's
way of telling Watson everyone hates you
but me the wink at the end is a nice
reference to the fans but Sherlock
wouldn't have known
was going to happen on the rooftop
whenever he recorded the DVD so there
isn't anything to read into it beyond
that number eight the newspaper
Lestrade passes someone with the
newspaper saying the game is back on
he doesn't seem unusually surprised so
does this mean that he was in on the
faked death like Molly was he generally
didn't seem concerned when anderson was
convinced of Sherlock's imminent return
and we haven't seen him grieve at all
like Watson or mrs. Hudson which also
begs the question of Mycroft Mycroft is
so connected in the British government
he knows everything
the character is generally known to be
very cold emotionally so his reaction to
the headline at the end of series two
could have been genuine or just a nod
that he knew Sherlock's secret plan was
working
number nine even though he was only a
silhouette in the mini episode Benedict
Cumberbatch did film with the rest of
the crew but since the mini episode is
serving the same purpose as the Doctor
Who 50th anniversary mini episode we
probably won't see any of the footage
from this mini episode in the first
episode empty hearse that means that
when Sherlock finally explains what he's
been doing for the last two years it
will probably be a different montage and
number 10 why is Sherlock going to such
great pains to hide his return and why
is he solving crimes around the world
the second one is easy remember during
Hound of Baskerville where he almost ran
mrs. Hudson through with the harpoon
because boredom was driving him mad
clearly he's just solving crimes to keep
from going crazy and all the secrecy is
just an extension of his plan to make
sure Moriarty's henchmen aren't a threat
to his friends anymore there's also a
mystery person that Mycroft references
during the series 3 trailer the person
that Sherlock cares about more than
anyone else I'll talk more about that
mystery person in a separate video but
honestly I really enjoyed the mini
episode I think we would have been happy
with just about anything though it's
been 2 years since we've seen new
content so fans have been going crazy
Benedict Cumberbatch was the most
reblogged person on tumblr this year
that's how much people want Sherlock
content since this is the same crew just
to compare it to the Doctor Who 50th
anniversary of mini episode I don't
think it quite holds up to the scope but
in all actuality even though we waited
two years for new Sherlock content
people were waiting over 18 years to see
Paul McGann as the doctor again so it's
not really a fair comparison honestly
it's really just meant to get fans in
the mindset that the game is definitely
very much back on if you want to learn
all about that other person on the other
side
that game you can click here to learn
all about the villain and get some
spoilers and you can click here to get
my top 10 moments on Sherlock so far
thank you so much for watching and Merry
Christmas and many happy returns
high-fives
you